مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه ربما يقترب
مخزونها من الذخائر من النفاذ بحسب تقرير
لمجله نيوزويك المجله نقلت عن مؤسس
المجموعه يفديني بريجوجين قوله ان الجيش
الروسي توقف عن تزويد مجموعته بقذائف
المدفعيه والسبب العلاقات المعقده مع
المسؤولين الروس ودون ان يحدد منهم اضاف
بريغوجين ان المسؤولين العسكريين الروس
يتجاهلون مطالبه بل وفرض قيودا جديده على
مشتريات المجموعه من الذخيره كما اوقفت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قدره على تجنيد
السجناء ومنعته من استخدام مناطق تدريب
تابعه للجيش كانت قوات فاجنر لعبت دورا
محوريا في الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن يبدو
انها بدات تفقد نفوذها بسرعه خاصه مع
استبدال عناصر من فاجنر بقوات من الجيش
على طول الخطوط الاماميه في منطقه دنيا
اليوم انتقد بريجوجين صراحه وبالاسم و
[موسيقى]
يصدر رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع امرا بعد
امر يمنع تقديم الذخيره لفاجنر ومساعدتها
في النقل الجوي جاءت المعلومات للتو تفيد
بانهم رفضوا حتى امدادنا بمجارف حتى لا
يتمكن الرجال من الحفر هناك ببساطه معارضه
مباشره ومستمره وهي ليست سوى محاوله
لتدمير يمكن ان يقارن هذا بالخيانه العظمى
الان عندما تقاتل فاغنر من اجل باخموت
وتفقد المئات من مقاتليها كل يوم